I love that feeling when
it's the beginning of fall
and it's 55 degrees outside
and it's finally cold enough
to wear my favorite
winter sweater and jacket
and beanie and gloves.
And I drink pumpkin spice lattes
to stay warm.
But I also love the feeling when
it's the middle of winter
and out of nowhere it's 55 degrees.
So I leave my parka home
and go outside in my
shorts and t-shirt
and I feel the warmth of the
sun on my skin.
And I consider going to the beach
to tan because it's so warm.
The temperature is the same
but my reaction to it
is vastly different.
Part of the reason why
is that there's more of a substance
in my body in January
as compared to September.
It's the same substance that allows
kids and teens
to handle the cold weather
better than adults.
When you're hot,
you sweat.
When you're cold,
you shiver.
But just before you start
to shiver
your body actually does something else.
It starts to burn fat...
but not the fat we
usually think of.
There are two categories of fat
that we like to think about.
There's the white fat.
White fat is the one that we tend to
just think of as “fat”.
It's called white because
it looks white.
White fat exists all throughout the body
cushioning our bones and organs.
That's Dr. Aaron Cypess,
by the way.
White fat cells have many functions
one of the most important being that
they're the body's primary
energy source.
Every single day we are
using the fuel
that's inside the
white fat cells.
But there's another type of fat
that has a totally different function:
Brown fat.
These cells are much smaller
and because of that, resemble
muscle more than fat.
Instead of one large
lipid droplet
in a white fat cell,
the brown fat cell
is one tightly packed bag
of mitochondria.
This is what gives it
its brown appearance.
And if you remember anything from
high school biology class...
you know that the mitochondria
are the powerhouse of the cell.
Brown fat, instead of serving as an energy
reserve for organs
throughout the body to burn,
uses its power to burn energy
on its own.
And unlike white fat
it's only located in a few
tactically positioned areas.
It is in the neck, the shoulders,
in the upper arms.
It's down the spine and then
some places within the belly.
Lots of overlap with major blood vessels
because warming the blood effectively warms the whole body.
The brown fat around the neck vessels
heats up the blood,
goes to the brain.
That's good.
The brown fat depots
in the shoulders
that blood, once it's been
heated by the brown fat
goes right — very quickly,
into the heart
and then can get pumped
to the rest of the body.
And that's the first line of defense
against the cold.
If it's not enough to raise the body
temperature sufficiently...
then the body shivers.
But one of the craziest things
that I learned while researching
this story is that...
babies can't shiver.
When babies are born
they do not have the muscle mass
and perhaps not even
so much of the coordination
with the brain and the muscle
to shiver effectively.
So they need other ways
of generating heat
and brown fat is part of that.
Babies are born with
a lot of brown fat.
According to the Cleveland Clinic
about 2 to 5% of a baby's body weight
is made up of this stuff.
It's necessary for our survival.
The peak age for brown fat
actually seems to be in the teen years
which explains why a lot of the guys
in my high school
wore shorts in the winter.
But as we get older, our body
makes less of it.
And this could give us
some insight into
why kids seem to run hot
and our parents or grandparents
seem to run cold.
Older people...
they certainly have much less
brown fat...
in terms of absolute
and relative amounts.
There's also less muscle
which is also important
for generating heat.
The similarities between
brown fat and muscle
don't end there, though.
If you work your brown fat out,
it also increases volume.
And the way you do this is
by exposing yourself
to the cold for extended periods of time...
as this 2014 study shows.
Look at how much more brown fat
these men from Maryland
had after a month of exposure
to cold temperatures.
And look how much less they had
when exposed to warm temperatures.
Which gives us some insight into
why 55 degrees in the winter
can feel so much warmer
than 55 degrees in the fall.
Brown fat doesn't just
keep you warm, though.
Scientists have figured out
that having more of it
correlates to lower risk of
diabetes and heart disease.
Studying the effects of brown fat
using cold exposure
is challenging, though.
One challenge is that
it's hard to dose cold.
How much... I gave you ‘this’ amount of cold.
I mean, you know the temperature, but
it's hard to know what you're doing
and therefore it's very hard to design a study
where it's reproducible.
So instead
they're trying to activate
brown fat with medicine
to study how burning it
affects us biologically.
A medication called Mirabegron
which is approved to treat
overactive bladder
was able to activate the brown fat
in a way that was very similar
to the effectiveness of the cold exposure.
There's a lot we still don't know about brown fat...
but we do know that our bodies
use it to adapt to cold weather.
And when a kid doesn't want
to put a coat on in the winter
it’s not necessarily that
they're just stubborn.
It might just be because they have
a little more of something
in their body
than you do.